not only his Netflix been spearheading a
massive change in the Hollywood
marketplace as a whole but the digital
streaming service has also built an
original programming sleep that's
challenging award season norms and
giving some beleaguered actors another
shot at thriving in the same game here
are some stars who've enjoyed a serious
second career win thanks to Netflix Adam
Sandler it's no secret that Adam
Sandler's filmography is a divisive one
some of his earlier picks earned wide
appreciation like Billy Madison the
waterboy and Big Daddy
others were passion projects built for
the critical crowd like Punch Drunk Love
and funny people but some were liked by
almost no one and since it's his
commercial success that's carried
Sandler through decades of off-the-wall
film fare that batch of box-office
bummers and critical letdowns has become
problematic for Sandler the price is
wrong [ __ ] consider the critically
obliterated Jack and Jill and his flop
dad comedy that's my boy even his would
be smash pixels failed to live up to the
hype which proved unmistakeably that
Sandler signature stick wasn't landing
quite as well as it used to but Netflix
still had faith in the slapstick
comedian and provided him a platform for
a whopping eight movies that people are
actually watching as of April 2017 a
half billion hours of Sandler projects
had been screened on the site between
the ridiculous six the do-over and Sandy
Wexler with at least a handful of
Sandler films left to go on the site
there's no doubt he's a company man for
Netflix now natasha Lyonne in the 90s
natasha Lyonne was a bona fide movie
star for a brief spell with leading
roles in films like slums of Beverly
Hills in American Pie somewhere along
the way of gearing up for the sequel she
lost her traction in Tinseltown and she
started landing just--but parts and TV
shows and little scene movies but
netflix has hit series orange is the new
black came along at just the right time
for her as she was still a recognizable
enough face and her talent hadn't budged
an inch in her absence from the
spotlight in the series she stars as the
troubled inmate Mickey Nichols who
vacillates between being among the most
earnest and intelligent members of the
Litchfield prison population - the most
damaged and uncontrollable of the lot
it's a meaty role for Leone to delve
into even if she doesn't appear in every
single episode and she started to pick
up more prestige work as a result of the
series like a recurring role in
Portlandia ethan embry as a child star
of the 80s ethan embry was a
absolute hit maker with feel-good
holiday favorites like Dutch and all I
want for Christmas even as teen years
were kind to his career with his
memorable supporting roles and Empire
Records that thing you do and can't
hardly wait but somewhere around the
turn of the millennium every star status
started to significantly fade he still
did enough work to keep the lights on of
course with the caliber of films and TV
shows he was earning placement and was a
far cry from the mainstream movie scene
he'd grown up in his recurring role in
Netflix as Grace and Frankie however
seems to be turning the tide not only is
it the first truly regular TV role he'd
had in a decade but it's given him a
chance to fully break away from that
wholesome cherubic boy him and she'd
been associated with for so long oh
great
we did it haha Brit Marling
this Chicago native has had more than
her fair share of splashy screen moments
in her still young career count another
earth and sound of my voice among her
buzziest projects but Brit Marling has
still had trouble establishing herself
as a leading star despite noteworthy
attempts on the indie circuit until
Netflix came along and gave her fever
dream project the oay a chance overnight
she went from that woman you might have
seen in the background of that one movie
to a completely compelling show creator
and lead star whose continued work on
the series was heavily in demand for a
second season and whose future project
ideas are undoubtedly going to get the
top of the pile treatment from here on
out rosario Dawson it may be hard to
believe that Rosario Dawson's career
ever needed a shot in the arm but after
the actress hit it big with films like
men in black - seven pounds in Sin City
casting directors appeared to cool on
the actress for several years before she
nabbed a prime place in the Marvel
Netflix show universe starting with
daredevil in 2015 she since reprised her
role as Claire temple through almost all
of the sister properties and appears to
be recapturing her mainstream momentum
even outside of the MCU with parts in
the Lego Batman movie and x-men the new
mutants Deborah Ann Woll True Blood fans
were widely taken by Vin newcomer
Deborah Ann Woll vaccine screen presents
but she's had a hard time establishing
herself outside of bond Tom ever since
that HBO series came to an end thanks to
a series of straight-to-dvd fare it
seemed like wool might not ever find her
niche outside of the sang banging scene
luckily she earned a top spot in
Netflix's daredevil adaptation just in
the nick of time and now she's spanning
the net flea
see you series with her character Karen
Paige appearing in The Punisher and the
defenders Winona Ryder for over a decade
Winona Ryder had reached icon status in
Hollywood thanks to her unforgettable
on-screen presence in films like Edward
Scissorhands Beetlejuice and Girl
Interrupted
but her reputation went very south in
2001 when she was caught shoplifting
from a department store she had a great
deal of trouble reaching the a-list
again after that even despite some
notable performances in films like Black
Swan and the Iceman
but Netflix is stranger things has put
her right back on the map with her
delightfully off-kilter turn as Joyce
Byers the mother of a boy who's been
kidnapped by a toothy monster she still
seemed as a little bit of a kook
especially with her ultra me mobile
appearance at the SAG Awards but thanks
to Netflix she's in the news for her
acting again instead of her legal
troubles thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]